salut à tous aujourd'hui c'est le jour
de la ferraille pas qu'on va rapporter
tout ça chez le ferrailleur et on va
voir combien on peut en tirer
mais avant ça je vous laisse découvrir
un petit récap de nos trouvailles on
attaque tout de suite sur cette portion
du canal du midi il fait un temps
magnifique tout est en fleurs qui ça
promet j'ai un gros morceau
ça commence bien dollars
je suis pas un lâche lousse
vincent et moi à côté en plus frontières
a où l'accord de bouche
sa terrasse bien peu si nous très
longtemps tue 3 ça fait 2 kg du coup bon
c'est le même bouquet cd bout du même
véhicule que la première fois nous a
attendus bien sagement et pas bougé
toujours le renault gris pas trop
identifiables
[Musique]
on fait comment alors il est venu à une
exploration voir ce qu'on faisait mais
il est pas discret avec sandra
à
nathan
de ce camp
des gangs
c'est encore un beau bébé sais pas si
c'est pas le capot non pas sur en fait
non je crois pas ça serait bien d'avoir
un peu en arrière un peu un capot koala
ça c'est une fourgonnette et moi on
ramasse des bouts de voitures la
carcasse way
on a sorti celui-là
on va la refaire
c'est pourquoi les colonnes au logis
ouais ouais ont été pollués
alors non mais c'est cracher des
raccords dénouement la trappe comme vous
n'êtes pas de quand peut on ferme à 2,4
déroule pas dans quelle époque on va
devoir plaisir
le portugal a placé un beau morceau
merci merci beaucoup
sandrine trioux les bombes allaient bon
train
merci
c'est à dire on va bien yann touche un
bond de 10 20 kg
à celle averti
ah mais c'est le il était en pleine nuit
à l'essai des gros aimant à mais c'est
le vrai c'est la boîte de vitesses ouais
ils passent encore bien pour il accroche
un peu sur la première mais alors là
c'est bon hop et hop ça c'est bon c'est
encore bien je vois la magnifique
magnifique
allez on continue
bon voilà donc ce qu'on vient de sortir
ouais on dirait que pour bout de
ferraille difficiles à identifier il ya
peut-être cette partie là arrière qui
fait penser un peu un bateau but de pato
de quelque chose qu'elle sera content et
je lis des pollutions aux boules de
pétanque
ça dépend si je vais m'écarter un peu
quand tu la sors de l'aimant et on va
voir si c'est une boule de pétanque une
grenade mais le pied dessus c'est bien
parti pour la péter en tout cas je me
mettre à couvert
on aurait dû la garde et l'impact de
fans qui m'ont très vite sous
d'accord c'est cette ville de pétanque
mais elle a un siècle
voilà pourquoi petit fer à cheval
un petit nom fer-à-cheval pas mal pas
mal de temps déjà là donkey 5 centimes
sûrement 5 centimes d'euros
pas mal de barres de fer on continue
alors là de au début on a cru que c'est
une bande incendie avec le rouge comme
ça mais l'on sait peut-être un
débitmètre un bout de compteurs d'eau
ouais ouais c'est du bois en 3 4 kg face
à face ils ont peut-être plus à partir à
l'affairé encore un le troisième se sent
en avaient dit jamais deux sans trois on
l'a eue appareils pas trop vieux non
plus pas trop vieux
[Musique]
tu vas aller langues
voilà pour le chargement on arrête là
sous la voiture il va finir sur les deux
roues arrière on verra combien ça fait
un emploi
[Musique]
les ans
quand je pense
[Musique]
on attend
nous
exotisme à martin qui fera
[Musique]
on va chez le ferrailleur tricolore jour
marché paulo bon gros dixièmes de la
micro achats paulo
vas-y ses lapins champions
là encore le débat
[Applaudissements]
à tête amoureux
une bonne
à
pourquoi
les trajets comme dessus 0 1
m
[Musique]
oh
rien
voilà donc pour ce qui est de la
ferraille en a fini avec sa voix là on a
réussi à emmener plus d'une tonne de
ferraille
voilà on a reçu 100 euros puisque c'est
100 euros la table on a décidé de garder
la grande affiche du quai ouest pour sa
valeur un petit peu historique et voilà
on la met dans la cave pour l'instant
merci en tout cas d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas en commentaire à
nous dire ce que vous en pensez à nous
parler de vos trouvailles et même de vos
dépollution
[Musique]